welcome to this episode of the future
verse brought to you by Intelligence
Squared and white tree I'm Kamal Ahmed
white tree was founded in 2017 to give
their clients insight and advice about
their money and life white tree calls
this Insight Financial life intelligence
at the heart of this idea of financial
life intelligence sits the vision of a
world where wealth is defined by how you
live not what you have that's where the
future verse comes in a space to explore
the conversations ideas and insights
that are driving change and shaping our
future
this week we're introducing a new theme
in the future verse redefining Legacy
over the next three episodes we'll be
exploring what it means to leave a
legacy in today's world but today we're
getting right to the heart of one of the
biggest decisions any parent with means
has to make do you leave much or all of
your money to your children
or will you do them and Society harm in
doing so are we morally obliged to focus
on the greater good whatever that may
mean over and above our own offspring
do these conflicting impulses have to be
at odds and should wealthy parents even
be allowed to make this decision should
he be outsourced to governments via a
wealth tax so our question today is is
the kindest thing a parent can do for
their child and for their world to leave
them nothing
I'm joined Now by three guests to
discuss this question
Professor Peter Singer is widely
regarded as the most influential
utilitarian philosopher of the 21st
century his 1972 essay famine affluence
and Morality In which he argued in favor
of donating to the global poor inspired
a global movement effective altruism
he's currently professor of bioethics at
Princetown University and is the founder
of the life you can save a non-profit
that inspires and empowers people to
take action in the fight against extreme
poverty Adrian Wooldridge is the global
business Economist of Bloomberg opinion
and former political editor at The
Economist as well as author of its
bayshod column his latest book is the
aristocracy of talent how meritocracy
made the modern world
Julia Davis is an angel investor a
lawyer philanthropist and environmental
campaigner dedicating her time skills
and resources to tackling the climate
and environmental crises and
interconnected social issues we Face
she's also a member of patriotic
millionaires UK campaigning for
increased taxes on high-level wealth so
I'm going to start by asking you one
question in turn what is the kindest
thing we can do for our children leave
all or very little of our inherited
wealth to them Peter let's kick off with
you what's the answer
okay but first I have to say that to me
that's not the decisive question
um it's not what is best for your
children only but it is what is best for
everybody and of course your children
can't as part of everybody but uh I
wouldn't think we should determine this
question just on the basis of children
if if in fact everybody in the world was
comfortably off and there were no causes
that you needed to donate to then maybe
it would be better to give a reasonable
large amount to your children for better
for them but in the world in which we
live I think that it's better
to leave them enough to survive on I
don't think we should leave our children
bereft but I think there are so many
other people in great need and there are
other causes that need our support that
we should
leave a relatively modest amount to our
children
thanks so much Peter Julian let me come
to you so Peter let's leave them let's
leave our children something but
um not too much Julie are you in a
similar type of space
well one like Peter I think that we do
need to think about the wider picture
and my view is that what is good for for
my children is also what's good for the
wider world because you know my sons are
a part of the world
um and I want them to live in a secure
world a world without greater conflict
than we already face hopefully less
conflicts
um I want them to live in a world where
they can enjoy the beauty of the natural
world as I have done and so that means
that for me
um in in looking after my children's
future it's really incumbent on me to
use my my wealth and my resources right
now to try to secure a better future for
them so I'm not really going to be
helping them if all I do is I just build
up more wealth to leave them after I
pass away I want the biggest thing that
I can leave my children is a better
world I would like to leave them a safer
World a more beautiful world in in
natural terms that that I've enjoyed
unfortunately I don't think I'm going to
be able to do that for them so for me
what I want to do is use as much of my
wealth as possible to do what I can to
securing a better world for my children
for other people's children and and not
just for people but for all life on
Earth so Adrian coming to you
the key question is is the kindest thing
to do to leave your children as a parent
very little of the wealth you may have
accumulated
I don't think it's necessarily the
kindest thing to do but nor do I think
it's necessarily the most important
question to be asking I actually agree
with Peter here the most important
question to be asking is what is good
for society as a whole and I think it's
probably better for society as a whole
that we have many points of Life many
potential many rich people who can uh
can act as philanthropists than it is to
have the state exercising Monopoly over
what we do with the world's wealth so I
would say from from the point of view of
the world
um the the good thing to do is for for
for wealthy parents to be able to
deliver a significant proportion of
their wealth uh to their children now I
would not defend
um the current inheritance laws in the
United States I think the United States
has gone too far in cutting inheritance
tax but I would say the inheritance
taxes it stood in about the year 2000 or
as it now stands in Britain uh would be
a reasonable model for for a healthy
Society Adrian we're going to come come
on to the issue of who decides which is
drifting into that wealth tax issue a
little bit later in the podcast but
that's really great that we've we've
started to raise that question now
it's your sense that it is for parents
to decide about what wealth they leave
and how do you have those types of
conversations as parents about what is
the right thing to do I must admit I'm a
parent of two young adults now similar
to you Julia and until engaging in these
types of conversations do you think
agent that many parents actually think
about this or is the default position I
leave my wealth to my children
I think the default position is that
people want to leave their wealth their
children I think human beings are sort
of naturally nepotistic animals they
look after their their children before
they do uh anything else but I think
that responsible people do engage in
those sorts of conversations and I think
that's particularly true about the ultra
wealthy I think Bill Gates is not the
only member of the ultra wealthy class
who is worried about the the impact of
you know huge fortunes on the character
of their children you know if you go
back to the late 19th century Teddy
Roosevelt was was brilliant on this
subject he said the problem is that
we're destroying the cat the characters
of our uh of our children by leaving
them such enormous amounts of money and
a lot of what he did when he was trying
to introduce the the the the the you
know the the first inheritance tax in
the United States was he was concerned
about the the moral
um nature of the American upper classes
and he worried that if they had too much
money given to them they would become
decadent so his his wealth tax was a way
of making them sort of stronger in the
darwinian sense
thank you Adrian
Julia can I bring you back in
when you're considering around
the wealth that your children may
inherit but I want to get this more
broadly it's not about your children
young men it's all about your children
but when you're thinking about that as a
parent and speaking to other parents
do you think as Adrian is saying
um that inheriting huge amounts of
wealth is actually damaging for children
I know there's the broader issue that
Peter has brought in around the bigger
Society is the more important question
but actually just for the children
themselves of maybe High net worth
individuals or parents who have been
successful in their lives and their
careers and their Journeys in monetary
terms is it damaging to children to for
them to Simply inherit large amounts of
money because presumably they could do
with that wealth something that is good
as you describe it
um personally I do think it's damaging I
don't want um whether whilst I'm selling
out live or or after I pass away I don't
want my children to to have the
responsibility or or indeed the um
feeling that they don't responsibility
of that wealth uh in terms of taking the
decisions on what they do with it
because I think that's something that's
better
comes to take those decisions when
you've got a bit more maturity and I
also don't I want them to have to make
their own way in life I also don't I
want them to be part of society and in
many ways wealth gives you freedoms but
I think also it can take away Freedom
you know I'm someone I've never wanted
to own uh very expensive things because
if I lose something if I lose an earring
it really doesn't matter to me because I
have taken a conscious choice I don't
want to own expensive jewelry if if my
car gets scratched it's oh that's a
shame but it doesn't upset me and I
don't have to worry about where I park
my car I want the freedom to feel happy
walking amongst other people and I think
that some people have so much wealth
they now fear other people you know they
have lots of land and they spend a lot
of time worrying about how they keep
people off their land and for me I want
to live in a case society which itself
has wealths and I want to live in a
society which where the the differential
between those that the Haves and Have
Have Nots is much less than where we are
right now in society
um because I think that then everybody
has greater freedom because you know a
society where the the differences in
um in in life
experience it is as great as it is now
that that's never going to be a a happy
uh a society of great welfare or a
stable Society so
yes I think about that it can be
corrupting for for people generally
anyone to have extreme wealth uh and for
that to be on a young person who hasn't
you know taken had the life experience
of accumulating that for themselves I
don't think it's it's beneficial but I
also think it's not good for society as
a whole
that Julia seems to get to the heart of
the idea of financial life intelligence
is about what you do not what you have
and then how does that affect what you
think you would like to pass on to your
children and let's we've touched on the
monetary issue wealth
what other things as parents do we pass
on to our children
well I think that you know I I will keep
saying this I think with in a world
that's facing multiple multiple crises I
would like my children to live in a
world where there are still hedgehogs
where they're still pangolins where they
could still go to America to Africa and
they could still see mountain gorillas
um now they're very fortunate I've
already given my son some fantastic
experiences we we you know we absolutely
love the outdoors we love wildlife and
we've had the great Fortune to visit you
know many places and see many many
things but it's it's that's not enough
you know I want uh to to set a good
example to to my boys and show them that
I'm not just enjoying these things I'm
doing my best
um with with the resources at my hands
to to try to protect them
Adrian how do you respond Julia's notion
that even if you have been successful
your high net worth that you still in
consumption terms uh travel more lightly
now Adrian I don't know if you have any
particularly beautiful earrings that
you'd be worried about losing but
do high net worth individuals tend to
want to put their money into cars they
don't want to be scratched into earrings
they don't want to lose into land and
property and symbols of status
and actually
we need to reconsider what we think the
prizes of success actually look like
I think there's a huge variety amongst
High net worth individuals in terms of
what they do with their money what they
consider to be a valuable thing to do
with their money just as there is
amongst you know ordinary middle class
people some ordinary middle class people
value their cars enormously and you know
shine them and keep them keep them
beautiful and others don't I'm not sure
it's highly correlated with with the
amount of money that you've got but I
mean I'm not sure that that stopping
people from inheriting wealth will be
good for the natural world all bad for
the natural world you can argue the the
the the the the people who inherit a lot
of money have been quite good as
custodians for the natural world because
they've had Estates which they've
inherited over many many generations
they've tended to look after them which
would be let's say Edmund Burke's sort
of approach to these things they tend to
be custodians of the natural world but
I'm not sure that um whether that's true
or not whether you can actually
demonstrate that if we had the state
essentially confiscating everybody's
wealth in each generation that would
make for you know a better planet and
finally I would say that I think when we
think of the bigger issues of equality
of opportunity and what sort of tennis
Society has I think the most important
way in which privileged people transmit
their privileges to the coming
Generations most important way they do
it is through cultural capital rather
than through financial Capital so I
think if you're
advocating getting rid of concentrations
of wealth your infringing on people's
Liberty to do what they want with their
with their money without necessarily
doing the good things that you want to
do which is to end War
save nature and create a more equal
Society
Peter before I bring you in about
philanthropy and what is the best place
when you're thinking about philanthropy
Julia that must bring you back in to be
able to respond to Adrian's points um it
can be the case and there are certainly
wealthy people who have done great
things for conservation but equally in
the UK we have land let alone wealth we
had land concentrated in the hands of a
very few people and they consider
themselves to be good custodians of
their land but nature doesn't
um and unfortunately Nature has done
very poorly on land which has been owned
by very large wealthy landowners so if
you look for example at the
um examples of grouse laws or deer
hunting Estates they are very very
Barren Landscapes Julia thanks so much
Peter before we will come back to the
wealth tax issue is coming up later in
the podcast do
um of course stick with us fascinating
debate but Peter let me let me let's
push us on a bit to the philanthropy
question
um
you have lived a successful life
um in a world where you have managed to
accumulate a degree of uh wealth
um you've devoted a lot of your uh
career to uh discussing researching
understanding the philanthropic uh world
could you give us some ideas that maybe
might guide decision making
around how philanthropy should or does
best work for a better Society
uh thanks very much yes I think it's
important that people think a lot more
seriously about where they're going to
donate their money and I'm assuming that
we're all agreeing I think that people
should donate some of their money uh and
we may vary as to how much that should
be but uh I think it's very important
that whatever it is that you've decided
you're able and willing to donate you
should think hard about where it's going
to do the most good
because
uh unfortunately most people don't do
much research when they donate often
it's impulsive they've seen some
publicity uh that looks attractive to
them or some friend has said I'm giving
to this organization and they follow uh
but there's a huge difference in the
effectiveness of different charities and
I'm not saying this
um comparing Charities that are add
right frauds there are such Charities
but they're actually very rare and you
know you could give to any of the the
big well-known Charities and you
wouldn't be giving to a fraudulent
charity but
um in terms of how much good they do
with each pound or dollar that you
donate there is going to be a huge
difference and and that will depend
often on whether they are working
um within an affluent country or in a
low-income country let me give you one
example of this a lot of people will
think that a charity that trains guide
dogs to help people who are blind is a
Good Charity to give to of course it's
good that people who are blind should
have a guide dog to help them get around
it makes their life a bit easier
but it's quite expensive to train a
guide dog to help somebody who's blind
and and you have to also train the
person to work with the dog and uh
roughly uh estimate might be that is
going to cost say in the U.S something
like 40 to 50 000
um to train a guide dog
now
um in other countries in low-income
countries there are people who are blind
because they've developed cataracts and
they can't afford to get their cataracts
removed and they don't live in a country
with the National Health Service uh like
the UK where they would be able to get
the cataracts removed at no cost but you
can donate to Charities that are working
in those countries that um I've seen
estimates as low as 25 dollars for a
cataract removal let's say that that's
an exaggeration let's let's say it's a
hundred dollars
um but still even if it's a hundred
dollars you can see that you could
restore site in 400 people for the cost
of training one guide dog for one person
and clearly to have your site restored
is even better than getting a guide dog
so at a minimum the charity that is
helping people to get their cataracts
removed is doing 400 times as much good
as the charity that is training guide
dogs so people need to think about that
and they need to find the Charities that
are most effective in helping people and
you can do that now quite easily online
I've set up a charity called the life
you can save you go to the life you can
save dot org that will give you a list
of about 20
Charities that have been independently
audited and scrutinized to be highly
effective give well as another
organization that does that there are
other websites around so I would
encourage people to think about that and
to try to get the best value for what
they're donating just as you know most
people will want to get the best value
if they're buying a new phone or a new
car
but strangely they don't always think in
the same way when they're donating to
charity and I believe that they should
and Peter if I can just ask for a very
short answer to this is it a moral
obligation to give away your wealth
if you are a person who is middle class
or above in an affluent society and
you're spending money on things that you
don't really need they're not
Necessities then I think given the
inequality in the world and the extent
of extreme poverty in the world that
we're living in it is a moral obligation
to give something to people who through
no fault of their own uh battling with
much greater needs than you have
Adrian what's your response to the
notion of moral obligation for people
who have accumulated and have been
successful in their life a degree of
wealth
yeah I I think there that there is
indeed a moral obligation and I think
many many people who have a reasonable
amount of uh of of wealth do you feel
that moral obligation but I wanted to
suggest two things so I think we can all
agree that
um the philanthropy is a good thing
um and that philanthropy is one of the
justifications as it were for for you
know not having a hundred percent
inheritance tax
um that that having people inheriting a
certain amount of money that gives them
a certain amount of uh control over
their resources can be justified by
philanthropy but I wanted to suggest two
slightly more
um
difficult cases
um in favor of you know people
inheriting significant amounts of money
one is patronage of the Arts that rich
people
um the significant number of them do
spend money on Art and that is good in
general for civilization particularly if
it's not just a grand Masters but also
encouraging current artists to produce
their work that's one way in which you
you you can improve the overall quality
of civilization
um through batteries and I think that's
always been the case throughout history
that people with money have acted as
patrons to the Arts and that has created
a a better world and the second is even
more as it were controversial and that
is that rich people can often act as
sort of innovative consumers and that by
Innovative consumers they can act as
generators of Innovations and
popularizers of innovations that make
the World ultimately a better place and
I would say Tesla for example electric
cars started off with
rich people who had lots of money to
spend and if they you know they're now
becoming cheaper and cheaper and cheaper
so many significant problem solving
Technologies are brought to us courtesy
of people who have money to spend Adrian
you've just tossed in some very very
interesting ideas into this redefining
Legacy uh podcast
um Julia can I come to you
um
agent has said wealth has helped us
protect land you've challenged that
um he's now saying that wealth has
helped uh in the flourishing or
otherwise of Art and also wealth helps
with the notion of innovative
consumption but I wanted to move us on a
little bit but do touch on those if
you'd like to respond to those areas
um about this notion of the moral
obligation
philanthropy versus the notion of the
actual wealth tax which is uh obviously
a legally defined way of uh giving away
or taking away as it attacks people's uh
wealth uh once they die or during their
lifetime you've been looking at this and
campaigning on this issue around wealth
tax and how it should work uh
particularly obviously well only
obviously or in some senses in Western
developed democracies Julia give us your
sense around the wealth tax versus the
notion of voluntary for long
philanthropy using some of the
guidelines that Peter for example has
outlined can I just come back on
Innovative consumption and um
Innovative consumption that aren't so
good for the planet let's look at space
tourism so as we know many of our our
Mega billionaires have been um putting
huge resources once again into space
tourism once again at a time where we
have
um pensioners who are wondering you know
whether or not they can put the heating
on this winter
we have huge campaigns encouraging
people to walk their children to school
people to use their cars list use the
bus more and we have these people uh
developing space tourism so I would say
that there's been some extremely harmful
Innovative consumption that's been
developed by the wealthy to come back to
wealth tags
um again you know I think that
um
people that work they don't get to
decide whether or not a success a
significant amount of their income goes
towards tax goes towards Society goes
towards all of the things that we need
in society to our NHS to our state
schools to you know maintaining our
roads and when working people most
working people pay tax that really does
affect what they can then spend on nice
things like holidays like a new car on
clothes on you know activities that
their children can do
now when wealthy people and by wealthy
people you know I'm not talking about
people who have just you know done okay
and got you know a relatively nice house
let's just call let's talk about really
wealthy people people who've got more
than five million pounds in wealth or
more than 10 million pounds in in Wells
when they pay
the kinds of levels of moderate wealth
tax law which we've been proposing that
doesn't
um affect where they go on holiday how
many day holidays they have it doesn't
affect their grocery shopping it doesn't
affect what they spend on clothes it
just affects their accumulation of more
wealth and so um we cannot rely on
philanthropy we absolutely cannot so
there are some there are many many
wealthy people in our country who
continue to benefit from wealth that has
been accumulated from some really
horrendous activities in the past and
and people will say oh you can't go
backwards you can't go back into history
but I would say well sometimes you can
and so I I think that when you talk
about wealth that people have a lot of
wealth that people have is land and if
you went back in history and saw how
they got that land well you know that's
an interesting question
so for me we cannot rely on philanthropy
because if we could rely on philanthropy
we would live in a very uh just and
equal Society we would live in a society
where we are not massively depleting the
natural world where we do not have
um working people having to use food
banks where we do not have pensioners
that
um well potentially you know they're
potentially going to end up in hospital
because they can't Heat their homes
properly and then they probably won't be
able to be sent home from hospital
because they can't be sent home to a
damp drafty home so that's why we
absolutely have to have wealth tax and I
would argue that a wealth tax ultimately
it benefits everyone because we all
benefit from a better Society a society
where we have public wealth and not just
private wealth
before I bring you back in Peter
um Adrian I need to I can't resist do
you have a yacht
I I I don't have a yacht and India I
hardly have a car I must say actually
but my car's not in real estate at the
moment but I would say um to Julia's
points that the the you know the
examples she gave
um really were about Bezos and musk you
know in space tourism and they're both
people who haven't inherited significant
amounts of money they're people who have
made their money during their life so
we're sort of Shifting the the subject
of of conversation from inheritance tax
to
wealth tax which may be a reasonable
thing to do but it's not quite it's it's
not necessarily an inheritance tax
question
thanks Adrian uh Peter can I bring you
in on this philanthropy versus tax so
voluntary versus order
um which is the way how is the way to
approach and I think Adrian you make a
very important point we're talking about
it inheritance and wealth what do you
think Peter is the best way to approach
how we ensure the good society and how
people who have accumulated wealth
through their life are able to take part
in ensuring that Future Good Society
yeah I think it's an interesting
question and and I do think it's a
balance and I was uh interested in
noticing that uh Adrian did accept the
idea of an inheritance tax which is not
always accepted where I am in the United
States of course
um and there has been I think a a
downward slide in inheritance taxes uh
and I think that that's regrettable I do
think that states are not always the
most efficient ways of Distributing
um the revenue that they receive and uh
in particular you know they tend to be
rather cautious and bureaucrats tend to
avoid daring decisions because if
something goes wrong then they'll get
into trouble but if they just continue
to do what they've been doing before
they're much less likely to get into
trouble from the the higher ups and the
same will be true to some extent to
politicians so I think it is important
that
um there be people with significant
assets who are able to choose to donate
it and are able to choose to donate it
in Boulder and more daring ways than you
would get with the government and some
of those will come unstuck of course but
they're prepared to wear that and some
of them will be
pioneering steps that we will then
follow
um so just to give one example um the
charity give directly which was set up
by some people in Yale business school I
think primarily started giving cash
grants to people in extreme poverty in
East Africa
whereas you know governments were not
giving cash and probably you know
wouldn't have dared to give cash because
they would have said well people would
have said that the media would have said
you're giving away our money and people
are just going to use it for drink or
gambling or prostitution or whatever
else it might be but in fact give
directly carefully followed where the
money was being spent and that was not
the case
um not that none of it went for any of
those activities but um wasn't a
significant part of it at all people
tended to use it wisely and it was
really trusting people to make their
decisions as to what they needed most
and could spend the money on Julia I
just want to bring you in on this issue
around inheritance and wealth Adrian did
point out correctly there is a
difference between those two things do
you think though that they are
essentially uh connected that wealth
taxes and inheritance tax have to work
in tandem to try and achieve some of the
powerful arguments that you've made in
this podcast
well I'd just like to make sure that
it's clear I'm not suggesting that
inheritance tax should take
you know everyone's you know all of
somebody's money because absolutely it's
natural for people to want to leave
their children financially secure or who
else else is is important in their life
we talked a lot about Jordan but also it
could be your spouse it could be your
partner it could be you know other
people who are important to you
um also when it we're not talking wealth
tax or inheritance tax and philanthropy
aren't either or let's just remember
that if you choose to leave a legacy to
a charity in your will in the UK I don't
know the situation in the states that's
not subject attacks so you can do that
so inheritance tax isn't stopping
anybody leaving
um their estate to whatever charity they
choose to do so in the UK and it's also
there's lots of sort of tax incentives
not tax incentives but there's tax
um
you know we have things like Gift Aid
which encourage people to give
throughout their lifetime as well and so
they're not either or my point is that
we cannot rely on philanthropy because
it is voluntary and if we could rely on
philanthropy we wouldn't be in the
situation that we are in so I think that
we need all of these things we need them
um to be interconnected you know I
completely agree that um the state isn't
the best
um protector of land in in the UK you
know I remember when
um the government sold off all the
playing fields uh for schools you know
and not so long ago they were looking to
to sell off lots of forests so like I
said I you know I for me I put my trust
in a lot of the big conservation uh
charities in the UK for protecting land
and I think you know it's really really
important that we do protect that not
just for nature but for people too
because it's so important that they have
access to that but the the crisis that
we face in this world in in the world
require Central
really significant and really quick
action to be taken we need to to really
be massively transitioning the way that
we live our lives if we do have a chance
of reducing dangerous climate change and
whether what you care about is the Arts
or it is poverty in the in developing
countries all of those things you know
will will not benefit in in a world
where we are facing whole areas of world
which one inhabitable more and more
extreme weather events uh collapse in
our food systems and all of the crises
associate with that so
and and to address those issues you know
this is not me telling you this there's
just you know someone this is science
telling us this this is all of the best
um scientists who look into it we need a
really really
um global scale transition in the way
that we use resources in the way that we
uh provide our food in the way that we
we live our lives and that can only
really be done on the central level
though we do need that to be done by
governments you know I want all children
to have the ability to have a good
education and that requires Central
funding and it needs to be funded
through taxation because of course you
know wealthy people they they're not
sending their children into our state
system they are sending their children
to to you know private schools which
happen to be Charities you know so we
really do need we do need taxation to
ensure that people are contributing
their fair share towards uh making
making our world a better place for
everyone you know for rich and poor and
I would love to think that we can just
rely on people's Goodwill to do that but
history tells us that we can't
thank you so much Julia let's have a
final concluding thought for
um our listeners and people who are able
to uh watch this podcast uh Peter then
uh Julia and then Adrian
Peter we've been talking particularly
about inherited wealth
just try and answer the question uh
which really is about
how important is it that we get this
idea of inherited wealth right
is it fair to argue that if we get
the idea of inherited wealth and how
it's passed on to Future Generations
wrong
that will lead to a worse Society so in
terms of its importance
the notion of the handing on generation
to generation of inherited wealth is it
the most important issue when it comes
to considering how we promote a fair and
just Society in the future
I think that uh how we handle inherited
wealth is a major issue for the future
because it does mean that we establish a
privileged class of people who have
inherited wealth and who don't need to
work for it and have therefore more
power than other people do so it's an
important issue but is it the most
important issue in our time I think that
really it's it's very important that we
pass on values to Future generations and
that those values are ones that
encourage people to think about the
world as a whole and to think about the
problems that we're creating and
especially the problems we're creating
for those who are less fortunate than we
are
um so that you know if you say
should we solve the problem of inherited
wealth or should we let's say at this
video in a moment solve the problem of
climate change I would say that climate
change is the bigger threat to the
continuation of the world in which we're
living
um and that is the most urgent question
to solve whereas the question of
inherited wealth it's important and it's
you know as Julie's been saying it's
it's not that it's unrelated to climate
change because that yacht that Jeff
Bezos has uses a vast amount of fossil
fuel I'm sure to to move around climate
change is something that we really need
to deal with now
the question of inherited wealth has
been with us for a long time it may
still be with us for some generations to
come I hope that eventually we will deal
with it in a fair and Equitable way and
of course I'd be very happy if we
started that process right now but um
I'm not going to say it's the most
urgent thing that we need to do
thanks Peter Julia to you is getting
inherited wealth
the rules the guidance around it what
people should do the most important
issue for a Justin Fair Society in the
future
um I think it's an element of addressing
extreme wealth and I think that extreme
wealth is interconnected to all other
issues which we're facing as Society
including climate crisis in the
biodiversity crisis because the
consolidation of wealth in the hands of
those who are able to to spend it on
things that they don't really need
um and you know that they are
um not only you know consuming a vast
a percentage of you know the energy in
the world but resources in general so I
think that addressing inequality and
wealth is a part of the biggest
question that we need to address which
is is a a better and fairer use of
resources which is consistent with
continued
um life on Earth which is you know which
is of a Kind which we have been really
really privileged to experience and and
which we are now inflicting on other
people in the world who've contributed
much less to these problems with their
suffering uh the problems much quicker
than us but we will suffer them too
unless we address this and I think
addressing extreme wealth is part of
that problem it's all interconnected
thank you Julia Adrian final thought
how important is getting it right on
inherited wealth for the future of a
sort of fair and good Society
I think we've been discussing the wrong
solution to the right problem I think
the problem of vast amounts of inherited
privilege uh the problem of widening
inequalities of opportunity
um the problem of opportunity hoarding
on the part of the successful is a huge
problems which we need to address I
don't think
um confiscatory taxes on in on inherited
wealth is the right way to address them
I think it's the wrong way to address
them because it's an invasion of Liberty
I think it's the wrong way to address
them because it's not necessarily very
successful if you look at Sweden for
example which had very high indeed
confiscatory inheritance taxes right the
way up until quite recently it was also
a society with great inequalities of of
of power and indeed wealth the
Wallenberg family through confiscate
through complicated
foundations and ownership structures
employed more than half of the Swedish
manual working class in 1955
did got round
inheritance taxes extremely cunningly so
it didn't really work I think there are
solutions to the the broader problem of
inequality as I try to outline in my
book to do with um academically focused
schools to do with much more use of IQ
tests towards much more
um proactive gifted education
classes for gifted children to to do
with
earlier opportunity in kindergartens and
preschools I think all of those things
really address much better the real
source of inequality that we have at the
moment which is accumulated cultural
capital on the part of the privileged
fantastic Adrian what a great place to
end a really fascinating discussion a
lot for people to consider about how it
is that they manage
their own position and if they have been
successful in life and have accumulated
wealth how they consider how they pass
on
not just wealth but values to the Next
Generation and how they can use that
wealth to ensure a good and better
Society in lots and lots of different
and complicated ways thanks so much
Professor Peter Singer Julia Davis and
Adrian Wooldridge for that fascinating
discussion do join us again soon for
another journey into the future verse
and in the meantime for something of a
different perspective on money and life
visit why tree.com